Do you guys like to cringe?
I like to.
In case you haven't noticed I'm kind of a cringy guy.
Put me in any
real-life scenario,
and I just won't know how to handle it.
*Clip of professional Pewdiepie handshake with Conan plays.*
That was awful.
It turned into a high-five and it just fell apart.
It was...I never want to do that again.
*Laughs at himself*
But that's what makes me appreciate the cringe even more,
because I understand the cringe.
I bleed for the cringe.
So without further ado, let's go through some of my favorite cringe
Special TV Edition™️! Hooray.
You're really scraping the barrel now Felix, I love this because it's basically how I do all my intros
*professional sounding intro music plays*
*Pewds laughing*
*snicker*
*sounds of fumbling papers or microphone feedback*
*Pfhh, hah!*
- Hello and welcome
- Thank you, I never felt so welcome! How natural that was
He just turns around like he's so confused the look of terror
Hello and welcome
to this vi-de-o...
Hope you guys are looking for...
*hehehe*
I don't know what it is with TV cringe
It's just funny cuz it's so it's such an organic cringe
You know what I mean?
When that thing happened with Conan, you know
I know! You see it in my head. I'm calculating
I'm like, yeah, I'm sure they'll edit that out. Yeah, I trust the editing system that they won't draw attention to it
They will just cut it out. No! And that's why we, you know, it's live you get these beautiful moments
Okay, this one! My boy. My man
Richard! 30 second pitch, Richard! You're on television, live television
You got to give us a thirty. Second. Clip.
I watch this clip to get me going in the morning!
To get me boosted, get a nice big old motivational push just watch my man Richard killing it. All right, Richard chaas keys take it away
Get a nice big old motivational push!
Just watch my man Richard KILLING IT
Alright Richard Pachovsky, take it away.
Come on Richard, kill it.
Hi, you're looking for someone who has more...
than
..just a focus on
uh
technology
You're looking for someone
who has
No
Pewds: Ohh no!
Anchor: That's okay, go for it! Tell us!
Anchor: Just speak to me like we're sitting at the dinner table! Go ahead Richard.
Anchor: What do you have? What can you offer?
...
Richard: That...
Pewds: *groaning*
Pewds: Come on Richard, plz!!
Anchor: It's okay regroup for a second. No problem. Go ahead take it again.
And here, when alllll hope is lost
When Frodo lost the Ring, when the Titanic sank, when that plane...
*record scratch*
No...
When all hope was lost
Richard
Top 10 Anime Comebacks of All Time®
KILLS IT! He comes back and he kills it
ONE. THOUSAND. PERCENT.
Richard: Okay
Richard: You're looking for someone who is more than just technology savvy
Pewds: Ja!
Richard: ...someone who has customer focus
and international experience. A prob—a person—who is a problem solver
Analytical yet still has common sense. [Pewds: Yes!]
I'm that person. [Pewds: He's that person.] I have great
...customer...
...focused skills [Pewds: He does!] and great soft skills.
I...have the ability to take
end-to-end ownership of a project
And the determination to do whatever it takes to get the job done
Anchor: Fantastic, Richard.
*Pewds giggling incoherently*
It's so wholesome!
So glad he got through it! My man...
Richard! It's it's not a cringe. I just love the clip
You know that they're saying in a relationship what they're not doing in public they're doing at home. It's a bit more specific but
Great saying Felix. I know well this clip is a testimony of that and my god
It's probably one of the most painful fights I have ever seen on television
Thank You, mr. President, thank you. Good morning everyone and welcome to morning Joe Joe's back
Is here great to have you back?
We did lots of fighting over issues. So it should be a good show to know we do know. Oh, yeah, we don't fight
No, no. Don't do that, ok? Not on the air.
Not on the air! What're you doing, it's 6:03.
Well, can ask you a question?
Everyone knows you cannot hold hands at 6:03 (AM)
okay, you cannot do any endearing gesture at 6:03 (AM) touching hands you might as well given her a slap on the
nose
We're engaged I mean we've been engaged now for like 13 hours
(uhhhhh)
Do you think I should be able to hold her hand? (no, not at-)
603 not at 603 everyone knows that you'll be quiet. I'll hold your hand
My god, but there is a chance of hail in the morning after love eight will reach 13 - great
So pick the first day of the last month. Oh my god, I
Said this and I've said it before first of all never kiss anyone I mean, what's the point?
Don't kiss someone that isn't your girlfriend fiance or wife on camera at all. Just don't do it. Just don't do it
Just don't do it. Okay. Just don't kiss people. Just don't kiss anyone just don't want to kiss for this guy
It's like you know what?
Screw that rule.
I'm gonna go- i'm gonna- Im gon- *Gibberish*
'*+-. Moment of truth .-+*'
Woman: Ouuo.. Ahha,
Man: Hah, hahahahahaha!
Other man: Ok, this is going on.
Urruugh!
You had one job
Okay, you know how much shame I have to swallow for the handshake. What do you think?
I happen if I went into a kiss, huh? What would you think would happen?
Tehe, he hahahaha...
Okay, this really is great way or is it here yeah
He, hahahahah!
I'll just play it. Quarter o'clock. Yeah his phone rings and what is he doing?
*Throwing phone*
*Vietnamese*
Yeah, that's less awkward. Couldn't he have just muted it you didn't have to throw or chuck away your phone Jesus Christ
I love the sound
but
*Vietnamese*
Enjoy your broken phone and your lost job. Oh this one is this one is great to my man. Mike craft sick
He basically speaks just like I do
when it's unedited
if you ever want to know how an unedited pewdiepie video looks like
It's basically like this people trying to beat the heat and trying to stay cool and to tomorrow
and people
*Hard time speaking*
That's it guys hope you enjoy this video and to
Tomorrow
Don't get me wrong. Okay. I'm not ridiculing these people. I am merely celebrating it. We're a group of cringe.
We all know how it feels I love this clip because whatever she's saying it's just so goddamn
boring and this girl doing a copies in the background just realizes that she's
For the lottery starting tomorrow
Open until Friday the UAA will know
Can I swap my cell phone picked up from Tuesday through Thursday now students which
Everyone is welcome to sign up live from the newsroom Cara Minelli. W UF t news
She's like what is happening? Beautiful cringe? Where would I be without you?
I'm so pale
Today snow is
low, and one of the
snow fell in Seattle in other areas
This is the kind of stuff that you know
I would if I do with this on camera Brad and Brad - we'll just draw attention to it
So now if I ever mess up an intro you normally I just keep going and do it redo it
But instead I have to stop the recording and start again
because of these douchebags
these meanies.
This clip is so weird, okay. If I no one has to context behind this, please feel free to let me know
I don't know. What the Frick her problem is. I feel like it's a broken record. Look at the best. I
Look at her, what's she doing?
Like calling you daddy thank you. I can like it what just happened
What just happened there? She's just like they're communicating
It's not about the record this morning, but honestly, I feel like it was a broken record
this is like the best song I play that song I
Like calling you daddy. Thank you
So anyway, that's the best song ever. I really enjoy that. You got it daddy
I like calling you daddy his reaction to it is so wholesome. It's not like "you weirdo". It's
literally, like "Oh, thank you"
Calling you daddy
She should be working for the BCC- Jbww- hahahahaha!
No, no, no, no not on my cringe watch. Okay, this clip is
so
painful, I
Need a nuclear warning on this one. This is nuclear. Oh my god, Jesus Christ. Okay guys. Are you ready?
I'm going to press play three two one. Im gonna get a picture of you and then it would be posted all around?
And you'll be it'll happen in your office. Yeah, possibly you don't think so
Well, it depends, you know, you know, I've got some time in the camera. Why don't you stop by?
No, okay, um, oh
Jesus Christ what is wrong with the people, you know people talk about
Social issues and I'm like that doesn't happen you watch you watch the news and it's like right there
It's hidden in plain sight maybe because I never had a desk job. Maybe that's these you why would he say that?
You know, I've got some time and a camera. Why don't you stop by?
No, okay, this is in the context of I think some
Naked photos and he just drops in the weirdest tone ever. I got camera
She dropped some time in a camera. Why don't you stop by?
Yeah, I'll come by. What the hell
What are you where were you thinking?It's not as bad as the kiss thoughto, the kiss was worse. That was a joke
Bwthahahaha..!
Yes, I love this clip
That's right. I've seen them all. I'm just showing it to you cuz I like it. Okay
This guy makes a weird furry joke and no one laughs
And it just makes it so much worse
Okay, just hang out with my new best friend Bettina I
Think you sho- you two should get a
Hotel room or something a lot of action going on over there. Oh Charlie!
Probably most action you get in months huh?
Oh my god... (thhehe), oh yeah? whatswrongwitdemwstakjjnuttlluwwioioioi
Terrible joke why would you and they kept going my god you think my jokes are bad
Shishah sheesh (Family Friendly).  Ah, I need a minute. I need a break
It's we got my boy. I can't even watch this. This is going to do a spoken words now write write and
Tell us what we're about to hear
Just a priest there. It's just a freak, you know every style I notice a Comic Sans there by the way, okay
Years ago, they tried it years ago. They try this just put me in it (Beatbox)
Check it check it
Come on Dave freestyle try to read something from your book. Yeah, uh
I was wondering like surely Mo's rappers have some sort of hey, give us a freestyle
They just have like a go-to rhyme right? Maybe they're writing some song or something some material
That's what I would do if I had a rapper because I'm a but cuz I don't want to end up like Mike here
That's right. Everybody. I make an effort to not appear cringy. Here's like actual customer out here
What's what's the best kind of firework to buy wouldn't you like to know weather boy?
Kid's sketchy back to you that kid has been raised on a pure onion diet I can tell this is onion versus soy
Demonstrated right here. Wouldn't you like to know weather boy?
Asserting his dominance
straight away
delivered that line like a pull intent like that that kid made him remember his days in elementary school, so
Humiliating. This is a new day. This is too big
so basically they they came to rescue this hiker because they left a message in the sand and
You know a call for help by stones, you know, the classic mean send help with so
Here's a live footage of it you're making
Something please send something please
Thank god, she's okay
Probably someone did in fact send her news. What an absolute hero
We sent our team out to send her nudes and it worked out great
Everyone was just happy, great everyone was just happy, it cured the heat, it just... fixed all the problems.
Pazawananganoamawoananawelcomezarawewoal Pazawananganoamawoananawelcomezarawewoal
S- s..- Seriously...
t h e n   t h e    r a m p w h a i a i a a
I'm gon.. I'm gonna look at the cordcast while they say.. Let's go take a look at this whole-
Woman: Wait a minute, you're live on TV right now?<?
Man: Yes!
*Non-humanic sound*
What are they..-
P a z a w a n a n g a n o a m a w o a n a n a w e l c o m e z a r a w e w o a
Man: Then the roud ??????
S- S..- Seriously.
I'm gonna look at the forecast while they sing. Let's go ahead
We got our phase right before make it our phase now before workout. That's why they sing
All right
that's it for me for now lemon leave a like if you cringed leave a like if you...-
Check out a..-
another video..-
Id.. Hit that uhhhhh........-
bell button
*Pewds trying to speak english*
and um...
(long awkward silence)
(processing)
(where did he go?)
( I Don't Know.) -From The Other Translator
Right, I know you're gonna keep this just don't just cut it out there
We miss Sive. (brad 2)